[Music]
this package just came in
[Music]
get everybody out here hi chris congrats
on the film
i am so stoked to talk to you about
spiral because i feel like it just
tackles so much more that you would
that you would expect in a saw film so i
wanted to know
why is now the perfect time to tell this
story and what went into the decision to
tackle the topics that are covered the
weird thing it's
you know it's a lot of it's about police
corruption but
we you know this movie was written and
done before
any other stuff that happened last
summer so
that's just an odd coincidence that
it's you know coming out at the same
time
but um i've always been a fan of the saw
movies
and i just thought um maybe
if we sprinkle some humor into this it
might
be a different experience and i think we
pulled it off i think we pulled it off
so
a thousand percent after watching this i
was like thinking of the other soft
films and i'm like it would have worked
so much better had there been like
pockets of humor in it you know what i
mean i read i also read that you wanted
to put your own spin on the soft
franchise in the same way that eddie
murphy did with the buddy cop films in
like 48 hours
so i was curious did you call eddie at
all and get his input and if so what did
he say
no i didn't i didn't call eddie
i mean maybe we were talking coming to
america too but we never got into saw
but uh yeah the movie yeah it's kind of
an eddie murphy-ish take
in a horror movie because there there is
no eddie murphy horror
movie but uh yeah so it's like it's kind
of like that kind of cop
in a horror movie in a real in a gory
horror movie
and as scary as you know this film is
and as gory as it is i
i feel like we all know there's nothing
scarier than being a stand-up comedian
but obviously doing new things are scary
too
so i'm curious what is the fear level
for you venturing into these new
dramatic turns like fargo
and spiral uh what's the fear level it's
scary i mean it
i don't play it's scarier than stand up
for me
uh you know especially fargo that was
scary
i don't know but it's a good scary you
know i mean you know it's a good
like you're scared you're gonna hurt
somebody
like mike tyson i'm scared i'm gonna
kill him right now it just feels like
you know i love my kids i love my
you know i love my life in general
so in order for me to like leave my life
and act it's i gotta have better parts
and you know so i've you know i gave the
orders to the people that i work with
you know let's let's start thinking of
uh you know more dramatic turns here
you know things with a little more
substance to them
and it's been working out fine yes plus
you learn how to swim
so now you can tackle anything you know
i can tackle if you can learn how to
swim in your 50s
you can do anything
so samuel jackson plays your father in
the film
do you see samuel l jackson as a father
figure
uh i mean yeah he's 20 years older than
me so he definitely could be my father
uh he definitely definitely could be my
father so
yeah i mean i see him as a as an elder
and he gets you know i give him the
respect of an elder
you know i don't you know you don't talk
to sam jackson the way you talk to
you know tracy morgan
i mean you give tracy respect but you
gotta give sam a little more
so i definitely view him as an elder
absolutely
the first thing i wrote down to ask you
after watching this film
was who do you think has said the f word
more in their career you or sam jackson
ah that's a good one
i think i think sam might
have me i mean i i've definitely said it
more in
cable and netflix but uh in movies sam
absolutely let's talk about the traps
you know
what is it like coming in contact with a
trap
who comes up with this sick stuff and do
you have any input
you know what we had like a nice deal
where
i was in charge of comedy and darren
and the writers were in charge of the
traps and occasionally the two would
meet
and i could basically say anything i
wanted
as long as it didn't undermine
the the horror of the movie that's kind
of that was kind of what we decided on
is it like is it nauseous seeing it like
in person
yeah when you see somebody going through
it it's really scary
and especially some of those um
some of these traps you know it's
i'm not saying they're real real but
they're damn near real
so it's like people you know people
haven't gotten
hurt no one's been killed but it's like
you know it takes a minute
to get it right and comfortable on
somebody so when you have somebody
screaming you're like oh
wait a minute what's going on yeah it
must be bone chilling i was talking to
darren about the glass trap and he was
telling me how
they were used they used rubber glass
and how it like actually hurt you
and you're wearing goggles yeah the yeah
stuff yeah
that that's a good example of oh you it
can take
out an eye so you know
but they just made it so they don't know
so
that's that's the thing about the traps
they're brand new nobody knows
exactly what they're doing and sometimes
people get hurt so scary
oh so gruesome i wanted to ask you about
your other films
too you know out of all the films that
you've been in chris
which do you think deserve sequels but
never got any
oh my god i mean i don't know i don't i
haven't
done like i mean we've talked about a
pewdie tang sequel
there has been there's definitely been
talk of a pewdie tang sequel
there's been talks been a lot of talk
about a good hair sequel
where i deal with uh natural hair
plus like my daughters were in good hair
and now they're like grown and in
college and whatnot and it would be
nice to show them with their natural
hair now um
you know maybe another head of state
maybe
deaf at a funeral somebody else dies so
somebody else has to die
somebody else always has to die i love
it
i wanted to ask you about the comedy
that you do infuse into this film
because it it starts off hilarious
there's this iconic joke about you know
forrest gump so
talk to us about you know infusing that
comedy and the decision to put that in
the beginning of the film and where the
idea for that came from
i mean this is there's a scene in a
in reservoir dogs where they're talking
about uh
like a virgin madonna well while
literally while they're plotting to kill
somebody
so i tried to like kind of steal that
vibe
it's like you know a bunch of killers
talking about forrest gump and
how it could never be made today so i
think i think i did a decent job i think
we got it
it's pretty outrageous but it but it
still feels serious it feels matter of
fact
i feel like i'm doing stand up you know
what i mean i know when you go into a
comedy special
your first priority is to be funny like
no matter how many jokes you've written
so coming into stuff like this what is
your first priority
my first priority when you're doing a
movie the first priority is the story
that it tracks that it makes sense
so and once you got a good story then
you can be funny
you then you can be funny and then it
doesn't seem so silly because you're
being funny
in a real situation so the first thing
is to really get the situation and the
script down hello detective banks
do you know where your officers are
i wanted to start off with asking you
about the traps
what comes first the chicken or the egg
like do they come up with the trap
and then write the story or is the story
written and then they come up with a
trap
yeah when you get the script that the
traps that are in the script are never
what ends up in the movie and a lot of
times it'll just be a blank hole it'll
say like uh
baz runs into the sewer insert boz
trap and the next scene it like won't it
won't actually say what the trap is and
then we
over the course of pre-production try to
figure it out
um and it's a team of people it's not a
single person it's not the writers it's
not me
it is it is the wardrobe the stunts the
writers the production designer the
producers
and that it changes the traps will
change 15 times and sometimes it'll be
changing up until hours before we
actually film the trap
whoa and so how long
is that process you know like once once
you guys come up with the trap how long
does it take
to you know make it well this is the
thing which is fun about the saw
franchise is that
we have engineers and effects guys that
will literally
spend weeks and weeks and weeks beta
testing the traps and sending us videos
so i'll give you an example
in the movie there's a trap that breaks
glass and shoots the glass out
so they built that for real and tested
it for real with glass
so they you know there's video footage
of them for example um
in a parking lot with a flat like a wall
and putting real glass bottles and
seeing
is it have enough power to actually
shoot the glass like we say we are
so we go through this really insane
rigorous process
of making sure the traps really work and
they do what we like so for the finger
trap we had mannequins that were
actually
seen will this actually work will it do
what we say it does and then once we get
that point to yes it works uh then
we begin to paint it to make it age down
and look old and gross
and then eventually gets put into the
stall movie so it's a
it takes months from the moment of us
figuring it out
to the building the testing until
eventually it ends up in a movie
i'm geeking out right now this is
literally the coolest conversation i'll
ever have
the i'm so glad you brought up the glass
trap because that was my favorite in the
film and in my head it was like
maybe you can you can talk about it a
little bit more that you've mentioned it
what did you guys was it sugar like what
was it so
so it's a combination of things we
actually had some of the cutaway shots
is actually plexiglas
that's actually flying into the wall
exactly as you see it um
when chris is in the shot or the other
actor is in the shot
we're using rubber glass which is a um
looks like glass it's rubber
uh that they're getting hit with but
that hurts by the way because it's being
shot out it's being shot out by air
cannons
so if you're if you're you know chris
rock and you're getting hit and it's
hitting you inside of the face
it's coming at you fast so um you know
when
chris is not looking like when his back
is swords he's wearing goggles just so
he doesn't get hit um
so yeah it's actually rubber glass and
then there was
some augmented vfx glass uh if it's by
their face for example
um and we can't put it by their face
because coming out so fast you'll have
so it's a combination of plexiglass real
glass rubber glass and visual effect
glass
it is just the team and and the artistry
behind it
is just so brilliant um okay so so they
make the trap
how does it go and then you test it out
and it works
i want to know how you make it come to
life after you said you paint it down
and make it look old because for me
darren it's not so much the visual that
makes my skin crawl it's the
sound so i'd love to yeah 100
i was i was just talking to someone else
about this to me the sound design and
the song franchise is its own character
as is the music
right charlie clowser who does the the
the music composition and he's one of
the few that have been with the
franchise since saw one he's done all
the music
um you know if you go back and re-watch
saw two
the needle trap scene if you if you turn
the music off and just watch the visual
it's not scary
what makes it scary is the sound design
and the charlie closer score which makes
you just like
uh tense up um it is the it is the
acting as well like if you watch
if you watch the glass trap scene it's
that actor uh patrick
uh his face contorting in horror
screaming begging
crying for help and the sound design of
the glass shards smashing and breaking
and that charlie closer music that just
that makes it intense and also
um you know a shout out to the dp jordan
orem
who who shot that thing to look
always hot and gross and sweaty
throughout the entire movie i think that
that all of these elements make saw what
saw is and make those traps what the
traps are
god you're so good at what you do this
is so cool i'm so happy you're shouting
out the team because it really is a
recipe for this beautiful disaster
and and i'm proud of myself for coming
up with that sound thing though too
because i was like it's really the sound
that gets you in all these stuff
you know what i'll tell you a funny
story that maybe i should not admit um
so we get npa issues always with the saw
movies they're always an nc-17
and one of the issues that we i learned
on saw three and i got this advice from
rob zombie
i could not get an r rating on saw three
i could not get it so i called rob
zombie who had a movie out called
devil's rejects
that i thought was much more violent and
i said rob how did you get
the r and he said sound plays such an
important role in the npa
strip the sound out strip the sound
design out strip
all of that out and it's like when you
present it back to them just show them
the violence
and so when you take all the sound out
they're like fine that's an r
because the sound adds so much you think
you're seeing much more than you are due
to the sound so sound is the one of the
most important characters
it's so interesting what do you guys do
with the traps when you're done with
them like are they in some sort of saw
museum are they your house in your
garage like where are they
uh that i have no idea some of these are
so
huge um such as the trash compactor one
or the glass one that is such a big
device um but there are some stuff that
that is put into a storage locker
uh in toronto because again you never
know when you're coming back i think
when they made saw one they tore
everything down they tore the bathroom
down
and they moved on then here i come on
saw two and i'm like i need the bathroom
back
so i think they learned to keep
everything for a few years
just to make sure because you never know
what the song movie is when flashbacks
occur and when we're going to want other
stuff
um but yeah so it all exists most of it
exists in a storage place in toronto
okay well hopefully no one breaks in
there because now i'm terrified
this guy's gonna break in there it's
okay if you do
um so i saw some rumors about a saw tv
series are they looking to expand the
universe what can you tell us about what
the future looks like for sci
and spiral i want to preface by this is
just me this is not i have no knowledge
of what lion's gate or twisted picture
is doing
but i think the idea has always been
with mark and oren
is they'll keep making saws as long as
audiences keep watching them
i think spiral kind of showed everyone
that
it doesn't have to necessarily follow
john kramer
in the same way that star wars and the
marvel movie have spin-offs
we can spin off the saw universe and
tell other stories
um so you know i wouldn't be surprised
if you saw a true saw nine meaning this
is the ninth installment of saw
but it's not saw nine saw nine it would
be a john cramer
costas mandalore story i think you could
see a spiral too i think you could see a
tv series a video game a comic book
uh there there's many stories left to
tell in the saul
universe and that's what's exciting is
you might see
a john cramer tobin bell saw you might
see another chris rock
you know whatever you never know and i
think as long as fans keep watching them
they'll keep making them
wait i thought that jigsaw killer was
dead he
is were you
a fan of the saw franchise coming into
this
i was a big fan of the franchise i
really loved saw two
that's sort of my favorite one um which
was directed by
darren bausman as well so it was very
cool that he kind of came back for this
one
yeah is it hard coming in and doing a
movie like this when you are a fan of it
yes no i would say it's hard i think
it's kind of exciting you know it's
really fun to be a part of a movie that
you know you would go and see
even if you had nothing to do with it
and i think we all felt that way i think
we all kind of felt grateful
to to get to play in this space nice
what was it like being on set i'm so
curious as to what it is just
being there because obviously we know
you know it's very gruesome it's very
gory
so what's it like being on set is
everyone just like covered in blood
it's a really nice group of people who
make these movies they're kind of a
family
you know that's what it feels like it
feels like you're stepping into a family
they're all canadian
so as we all know canadians are the
nicest
and uh we all work really hard i mean we
worked really hard
it was a fun set and there were lots of
jokes and it wasn't heavy
like it felt light but my biggest memory
was really how
kind of professional it felt and how
much everyone was putting into it i
think we all really cared about getting
it right you know
that's so interesting that you say it
felt very light so
watching it as an audience member it's
like the legit opposite of that
so i'm curious as to like what the traps
are like in person
you know and and seeing like this
gruesomeness and goriness like does that
stay with you
is it as scary like on set as as it is
when we watch it on screen
no it's really cool you know it's just
cool to see in person you know what
reminds me of is like
did you ever go to universe like
universal city studio tour or anything
like that
yeah it feels like that it feels like um
yeah it feels like you're getting like
to see behind the curtain of
um all this really uh exciting
make-believe
yeah that's a that's a funny um way to
compare it to i can like
totally feel that that's so funny you
have some powerful scenes
um with chris rock and samuel l jackson
so
we wanted to know you know what was it
like shooting with them
uh amazing i mean they're both
completely iconic
people and two of the great actors
um so it's very humbling and um
it's always smart i think to work with
people who are much more talented than
you
than you that's always been my game plan
is
surround yourself with people you can
learn from and and this was really no
exception
did you learn anything from them by
working with them oh my god so much i
mean
especially you know chris and i were
stuck together a lot you know in this
movie and
um to get to be able to pick his brain
and he's a great filmmaker as well as an
actor and comedian
and amazing writer and somebody i just
really look up to
aside from this experience so
um yeah i feel like i learned a million
things every day
is there one thing that you can maybe
share with us that you took away
yeah he's very professional he's the
first guy
on set he's the last guy to leave he's
very generous
he's very kind and i think anytime you
work with somebody that successful and
their manners are that good
it's always a good reminder nice is
there anything that you
shot with you know sam or with chris
that didn't make it into the film that
ended up on the cutting room floor
no you know what's so crazy is almost
i think every single thing i shot is in
the movie
um which doesn't always happen you know
and they were calling like in terms of
including a lot of
ad-libs and like riffs and stuff which
you know we
weren't sure was going to happen so um
they were very generous with us in our
performances i think in the edit
that's so cool i feel like that's rare
you know just to see
everything that you did like in the
movie so that's amazing
that's cool it's lucky yeah yeah a lot
of us know you know as nick blaine from
the handmaid's tale how do you think
that role
prepared you for your role in this film
not at all i
i love playing both roles i think what
was so
cool for me playing um william was
he's so different to anybody i've played
before he's much like
goofier and like um
more like wide-eyed and naive you know
than some
characters i'm normally asked to play so
uh
that was fun and you know i'm also used
to playing kind of romance doing
romantic stuff and there's like there's
no romantic
element to this movie whatsoever i mean
i guess we have a kind of bromance in
the movie
but everything about it felt like a new
territory
and i really enjoyed that i really
enjoyed having yeah having fun with
these guys
yeah you feel that bromance and
chemistry it's so awesome would you i
feel like a lot of people are going to
be wondering
you know walking out of this film would
you be down for a sequel
would you come back if you were asked uh
no
no question i mean i would love to do
another one
i don't think any of us want to count
you know can our eggs too early like who
knows what's going to happen you never
know
i really hope people go and see it and
they like it that's that's the most
important thing is that we get this
first movie right
there's also rumors flying around about
a saw tv series do you know
anything about that like are they
looking to expand the universe
um what what's in store for the future
as far as
and spiral goes they you know they don't
tell us anything
i think so that we don't have to lie
when we talk to you guys so
all i know is what you guys know you
know i read it in the trades along with
everybody else and
i i can tell you as a fan of the sore
franchise
i i think there's a lot of opportunities
there i mean
i think you could do all sorts of things
and i'd watch all of them what do you
hope people take away when watching this
film because it's unlike any other saw
film i've seen before
god i just hope they have a good time
you know like one of the things i'm so
proud of with the film is how
unpretentious
it is it's not it doesn't take itself
seriously at all
it's really a ride um it
you know it's not civic vegetables or
anything like that you know a lot of
movies nowadays i just
really don't i'm having a great time a
great time because i
feel like i'm being told off all the
time or i'm getting like a free college
class
and this isn't like that this is an
escapist
rollicking adventure and and those are
the kind of movies i like to see
they're hours not days how can i catch
this guy if there's nobody on the bus
i can fuss you can't do this alone
were you a fan of saw coming into this i
am uh i'm a super fan of horror
movies saw is probably the freakiest of
them i think you have to have like a
strong stomach
uh to watch the movies i still i'm like
uh
when it comes to the gore um but i love
a good thriller i love i love a good
scary movie i love a good serial killer
and i love a good mystery so i was i was
so in i love the good cereal
did you it's so true everybody does
this is america you know is it harder to
do
these film these types of films when you
are a fan of the genre like that
i think there's a little bit of pressure
to do to do homage
to it you know something that's been
existing for so long
and the fans are so avid it's a thing
i think it's like how people feel coming
onto riverdale they're a little like
oh okay all right and now i get it i'm
like okay no pressure
um there's there's a little bit of that
awareness that people have done this
before you and you better do a good job
so there's that right well you killed it
you mentioned you know for the audience
it is these movies are hard to stomach
sometimes what is it like being on set
do you get nauseous like is it is
everyone just covered in blood
like can you walk us through and paint
the picture of what it's like on set
um it's a little it's so funny it's like
the more
horrible the scream is and the torturous
the more giddy everyone is behind video
village it's hilarious
wow it's like oh that's going to be so
good and there's there's like an
excitement
to it which is the oddest reaction you
know
and you're sort of like poking the
prosthetic that looks real that's freaky
god what's wrong
with you it's really it's really fun and
that's i think
what makes it so exciting is i can't
wait i can't wait for people to see the
other side of it you know it's really
fun being on this side
but i've always been the one on the
other side experiencing it
in the theaters and being scared and
tortured that i'm i'm excited
i can't wait for people to see it yeah
it's interesting hearing your
perspective on that
it sounds like the feeling when you're
about to surprise someone
it sounds like that fun feeling you get
where you're like i know this is going
to be so good you know yeah that is the
perfect
description before like you know you're
going to freak someone out
and you can't wait and like wait wait
did you see their face and i can't wait
it's kind of like that
that's so cool thank you for that
obviously um i don't want you to spoil
anything but your character does come in
contact with a trap
i was wondering if you could tell us you
know as much as you can
tell us and how is that for you as an
actor is it hours of hair and makeup do
you get any input
it is um no the hair and makeup is not a
big deal i mean
there's prosthetics in the film and
stuff like that which you have to do but
as an actor you're like cool let's do it
awesome what's this gonna look like and
coming into contact with the traps
it's a little um you know freaky
it's a little like you know i was
telling someone else that when i met the
writer i was like what kind of
mind comes up
with these horrific ways to torture
people and choices
and i thought that i was going to meet
the writer and he was going to be like
kind of scary and kind of freaky and
like you don't want to be alone in a
room with them
and it's the exact opposite and he's
like this joyous guy
who's like can i take a selfie and hi
and like
so excited and it was it was like okay
so here's the fun part of this whole
world
um so it's it's you kind of that that
enthusiasm is
is addicting it's fun that's funny that
oddly creeps me out even more i'm like
are they just super giddy behind me at
the grocery store coming up with torture
destruction
i know how to torture that woman what
okay you know does any of this stuff
stay with you after
what's your process coming out of this
you know do things show up in your
nightmares
i get nightmares only being an audience
member so like
watching a film like the ring it took me
a long time to like
i'm not gonna be alone with a tv on what
if the thing comes crawling out or
whatever like
really freaky things like that they stay
with you
exorcist movies like that you're like uh
being on the other side of it
surprisingly it's not scary at all
because you're making it
like oh that's cool that's gonna be
awesome i can't wait for people oh
that's gonna freak people out
that's gonna be amazing that that's it's
just it's it's not being on the other
side of it it's more fun than anything
it's so great hearing that it's funny
you have some really awesome scenes with
samuel l jackson and chris rocks i
wanted to know
what was it like shooting with them and
did you shoot anything that didn't make
it into the film that you wish did
there was thank you for asking so first
of all chris i loved working with i had
so much fun bawling him out
and bossing him around like come on that
was amazing um i love that
like great um and then sam jackson was
just like i was like wow he's really
tall
and i'm not freaked out at all i'm cool
i'm cool i'm not freaked out at all i'm
cool
that kind of monologue in my head the
whole time um
and there was a scene in the bathroom um
in the men's room
where i kicked the guy out with me and
chris and that seems a lot longer
and there were some really beautiful
moments in there and levels
and you know fine it cuts down
i get it and it got cut down and it
still works
but i miss i miss that i really liked
what we found there and i wish that
would have made it maybe he'll be
in behind the scenes or something like
that can you tell us a little bit more
about
about what it was that was shot that
didn't make it in
um it was just a very emotional scene
and chris's character has to fight
harder
to win angie over to let him have that
case
because he's incompetent he's not a team
player
for lack of a better better word he's a
brat he needs to get over himself
and she doesn't want to give that to him
she doesn't believe
that he can take this on and it's too
important to trust
and he has to convince her to get her
agreement and so
in the longer version i was like
convince me
convince me win me over and i liked that
he had to fight harder for it
and i get what made the movie but i wish
i wish we could have had that longer
longer
scene for because i really liked it yeah
well thanks for telling us about it yeah
what was unique to your early prep work
going into spiral
like i said i'm a horror fan so for 20
years i was waiting for this
and i was like okay you know i'm not
familiar with jump scares and this and
the other so how is this done and when i
read the script
it reminded me of seven so what i did
was actually rewatch
seven um as prep work and
it really helped because you're creating
this environment
like with seven the environment was
raining
all the time in that film it's just
pouring rain and in our film it's
hot and it's sweaty and it's humid and
it's
like speed takes on a life of its own
and so i didn't want to forget about
that
in our film and so bringing that sort of
that element to
you know that humidity and disgust
you know as a female we hate that along
with
blackouts and a serial killer and
they're targeting us and so there was
there was a lot at stake it was really
it was fun to
hopefully bring all those elements into
the performance
[Applause]
[Music]
hello detective banks when was the last
time
you saw your father